[Music]
she's so happy
1 000 pound Sisters star Tammy Slayton
surprising her weight loss surgeon with
some good news on his birthday Tammy how
do you feel like you've been doing with
your diet
not good
fans of the TLC series might recognize
Dr Eric Smith who's been a big part of
Tammy's weight loss Journey
today I was finally able to get Tammy to
admit to me that she's not able to do
what she needs to do and she's admitting
that it's really hard to stop eating
last week the reality star ditched her
oxygen tank to show Eric she can walk
without it
that's awesome
[Music]
and it's just the latest milestone for
Tammy who's also been showing off her
dramatic weight loss on social media
after losing nearly 200 pounds
I'm not gonna I'm not ready to
toner towel it's one of the best moves
I've ever made it's enough for her
doctor to comment so proud of you look
at you
no oxygen yeah
um
[Music]